[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo programa de medio
ambiente del 23 al 28 de agosto se llevó
a cabo la semana mundial del agua que
normalmente se habría celebrado en la
capital de suecia organizada por el
instituto internacional del agua de
estocolmo sin embargo la pandemia de
ccoo y 19 hizo que al igual que nosotros
en france24 tuvieran que producir el
evento desde casa y de manera remota una
de las conclusiones del encuentro fue la
necesidad de resiliencia resiliencia de
las sociedades y también resiliencia de
los ecosistemas frente a la cada vez más
clara escasez de agua en el mundo un
ecosistema crucial para el
abastecimiento de millones de personas
en américa latina son los páramos que
funcionan como esponjas de agua estos
sólo existen en cinco países del mundo y
colombia cuenta con el 50 por ciento de
todos ellos sobre la importancia de
estos ecosistemas
hablamos con andrea yáñez gerente del
fondo de agua alianza bio cuenca que
hace proyectos de conservación restaura
y producción sostenible con las
poblaciones que residen en la zona de
influencia del páramo de santurbán al
noreste del país sudamericano
finalmente protegerlos nos dará una
garantía para la seguridad hídrica de
los territorios puntualmente el páramo
de santurbán que tiene una extensión
aproximadamente 141 hectáreas y en la
cual este ecosistema comparte dos
territorios importantes dos
departamentos en colombia uno de ellos
es norte de santander frontera con
venezuela y el otro departamento de
santander estos dos departamentos están
unidos por este gran ecosistema que nos
permite tener agua para más de 2
millones de personas que son sumamente
importantes no solamente por su génesis
sino también por la capacidad que tienen
para poder generar buenos indicadores en
términos ambientales de muchos servicios
ecosistémicos el tema de carbono
hidrológicos y servicios ecosistémicos
con el tema de biodiversidad y por
supuesto en calidad de la
durante esta semana mundial del agua se
resaltó también la importancia de
comunicar la crucial interdependencia
que existe entre el agua los seres
humanos y la naturaleza y como la falta
de conocimiento por parte de los
legisladores del valor que tiene este
recurso finito hace que se tomen
decisiones que van en contra de nuestro
progreso y desarrollo sostenible algo
que andrea yáñez achaca a la falta de
conciencia a la que señala como la mayor
amenaza a la que se enfrentan los
páramos no está oculto y finalmente esos
ecosistemas están rodeados de muchas
amenazas y de prácticas no sostenibles
generar la minería mecanizada en la
montaña y prácticas como la
deforestación la tala pero yo creo que
el mayor el mayor riesgo o la mayor la
mayor amenaza que puede tener un
ecosistema y sobre el páramo la falta de
conciencia yo creo que si no finalmente
no trabajamos sobre una educación
ambiental si no trabajamos sobre esa
participación de lo que es o valorar un
trabajo en términos sostenibles
yo creo que ese es el mayor riesgo
cuando no somos conscientes de lo que
está pasando que puede apuntar a una
amenaza mucho más global entre si hay
prácticas obviamente que están nos están
amenazando definitivamente muchas
prácticas pero definitivamente yo creo
que la peor amenaza de maduración donde
un tema de educación ambiental
otro de los mayores peligros a los que
están sometidos estos ecosistemas es la
minería el gobierno de colombia está
tramitando un proyecto de extracción de
oro a gran escala por una empresa
privada en zonas colindantes al páramo
de santurbán algo que según los
conservacionistas supone un peligro para
los recursos naturales de la región y
afecta ecosistemas que están totalmente
conectados con el páramo para el
gobierno de iván duke es una manera de
reactivar la economía del país afectada
como todas por la pandemia de kobe 19
desde el fondo mundial para la
naturaleza wwf crítica en esta postura
que una recuperación como está
planteando el gobierno no puede ser ni
justa ni verde y resiliente si se basa
en la explotación de recursos naturales
no renovables en ecosistemas y en
ecosistemas como los de alta montaña que
estamos hablando de páramos la
meteorización los cambios químicos que
suceden
ocurrir explotaciones mineras como la
que está planteada y otras que están en
otras regiones del país están generando
muchas tensiones porque primero son
territorios donde usualmente se hacían
otro tipo de actividades agropecuarias
no existe la capacidad ni la confianza
en las instituciones para que ellas
efectivamente tengan un adecuado control
de los proyectos que eventualmente
entren en ejecución y la posibilidad de
que unas explotaciones mineras como esa
constituyan al futuro pasivos
ambientales es muy alta en ese marco
jurídico e institucional que tiene el
país entonces los riesgos son muy altos
el rédito económico que tiene la el pago
de regalías y otros impuestos es muy
bajo entonces el balance costo-beneficio
consideramos que no es adecuado y que
puede generar unos grandes pasivos para
él
adicional a la el aumento del conflicto
social que se ha venido presentando y
que ha derivado en varios territorios
del país en el libro de vida para el
líderes que están protegiendo esos
ecosistemas
la empresa privada min esa está
pendiente de una licencia ambiental para
poder extraer el mineral y ahora tanto
el gobierno colombiano como la compañía
minera se enfrentan a una demanda por
parte del comité por la defensa del
páramo de santurbán es todo por esta
semana sigan con más en france24 punto
com
[Música]